once an idyllic street on the edge of
town
now a giant crater
bricks and mortar ripped apart
this is all that remains after russian
forces targeted the outskirts of bachmod
in eastern ukraine
many people's hearts and souls went into
building these homes
the war has destroyed so many
but some people are glad to be alive and
grateful for what they have left
thank god everything is all right what
is there to be scared about i have six
children five sons and one daughter nine
grandsons i've done everything in life i
could
his feet crunch on shattered windows as
he tries to salvage what he can
one of his few neighbors who's still
here offers him a cigarette
in the same town the russians hit this
dormitory with a rocket we're told it
was meant to take out a bunker
russians frequently used long-range
weapons to destroy targets anywhere in
ukraine
we found all of that stuff today in the
morning when i heard explosion i went
down on my knees and the shrapnel came
over my head
some people told us they had seen
ukrainian military in the area
the front lines are not far away
the russians are making a push for more
territory
an ambulance crew heads close to where
the battle is taking place
while they wait for casualties from the
front line we're given camouflage for
our vehicles
we've just had to take cover because
a jet was flying
overhead
and we had to spread out
but this is
what's happening on a daily
basis for even
those that are trying to
help the wounded
there's no let up in the fighting
we're forced to turn back
the constant sound of heavy artillery
can be heard and felt all day and all
night
assad beg al-jazeera eastern ukraine